okay so the first thing was the time
since we're gonna do Soto don't give you
a katana this way I mean into the room
don't have this day okay boom hits home
at the time
not early then obviously do not like
right at the time boom then you have
your movement and this is a universal
martial application once off this five
so this stretch is going this way you
see you're trying to get him to either
move around it will isolate his arm or
pass your arm into it
so his Perry goes like that you see and
that brings me to the arm so don't go
like this you'll contradict your
movement this way this way
[Music]
Virginia they stay hey don't move mmm
you see because you're going y'all on
the end you see that you're trying to
create distance out here did that puts
you in weapon room okay so all right and
we go and I'm gonna stay out here you
see DC you see I got that moves when
he's gotta close the gap we get that
okay so I I am very much like your net
was uh I'm setting up the wrist do you
understand and I don't set up the wrist
like that I set up the wrist here out
here this is where the fight is and
that's where my weapon awareness is okay
so as you're doing the first part here
you see how I'm out here out here
that's the wrist well what is out there
I'm not pushing him and I'm not pulling
him you get it this is the length of his
arm that's the bed I wanted my arm and
that's where I'll be
so if I'm here that was too close
if I'm here that's too far feel his body
where it's light right
right okay try it again
Thanks okay he strikes right oh come on
this way in do your my hands are here I
never go yeah see you come back but
that's not going to be there right you
can come on the outside
so all my weapons are here at my Center
boom boom boom in my Center and you guys
are doing this technique you got it
do you see that you're inside your outer
rim inside your other ready so if you
want your hand to go there what do you
have to do move your body so it's inside
your honor around you cannot go like
this look see see always inside and it's
not going it looks like it's kind of
going left to right it's really going up
and down hey
different
[Music]
a lot of it is you get there but you
start to look here focus on the wrist
you think the wrist is the center of the
technique at this point they try to get
here a little knotted if you like you're
still doing all of this right but once I
get here you see don't cut down get go
into his body
okay all this is the same I'm floating
here and once that touches it's it's
affecting his body okay you're doing
this stuff some of the mistakes is
you're going to go like that you see
that with it
that's not gonna work so it's not it's
not hard is it no but you're aiming
you're aiming it into him okay even if
he lets go you still have it
here you got it okay
you're just here start aiming that into
him
got it this year so don't do that
keep energy going up through the elbow
right and connect it to him and he can
let go and you'll still have it oh
that's that's what we want we don't want
this it's not going to happen you move
to the extremity and you target at that
ring
so he comes around okay hey he's gonna
have that pin you got that you see that
yes inside okay got a good grip on it
got it is that your bass you got it okay
I want to try it again
got it got it yeah good you got it
use all your muscle okay and tell me
when you're ready I'm ready okay
don't you do that if you're doing
awesome they got some dumbass like you
can't hold this so you have to develop
such detail work you're not dependent
it's not a gripping technique so we're
not when I come around it's not that I
already have this Center it's not grip
dependent even if you pulls his arm out
you still have the connection so first
get the connection right connection got
it it's up his arm you see and then you
do this and when you're doing it it's
the same thing
you're not cranking you have this same
connection you see that oh not here and
you're holding the place and then you're
gonna turn it down that's a pipe dream
you're out you're floating at the wrist
and both hands are aiming that is
so I know there's no point where I have
to use strength this is the contact
point and this is a contact point and
they're both
Kahless chest
you you're going to feel like you can
shoot him in like this well we're gonna
use this control to go here so now I'm
using that he's an intern
so don't go like that keep keep the
connection in his bodies you can always
project back right keep that connection
[Music]
here's the same thing I'm not shoving it
down he won't go to where I wanted to go
same connection
[Music]